نتواجد حاليا في المدرج الخاص بقاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه هنا بمدينه جده من
المتوقع وصول طائره الاجلاء الكوريه من من
مطار بورت سودان الى مدرج الخاص بقاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده خلال الساعات
القادمه وكما يظهر امامكم الان هذه
الطائره الكوريه الخاصه بعمليات او سوف
تقوم بعمليه النقل الرعايه الكوريين من
جده الى سيؤول الكوريه خلال الساعات
القادمه نتحدث عن 29 شخص سوف يتم اجلائهم
من مطار بورد سودان الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه هنا بمدينه جده بتنسيق
السعودي
نتحدث انه هؤلاء 29 شخص هم دبلوماسيين
كوريين وبمقدمتهم السفير الكوري هناك في
الخرطوم سوف يصلون خلال الساعتين القادمه
نتحدث عن تنسيق كبير تنسيق امني بين
الحكومه السعوديه والكوريه وكذلك كافه
الاطراف هنالك في العاصمه السودانيه
سوف يقوم باستقبالنا السفير الكوري في
السعوديه وعدد من قيادات القاعده هنا في
قاده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده
لاستقبالهم نتحدث انه تم تسهيل كافه
الاجراءات لوصولهم نتحدث انه سوف يتم
الكشف عليهم والتاكد من صحتهم فورا وصولهم
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هنا في
مدينه جده هذه الطائره التي امامكم الان
سوف تقوم باقلالهم خلال ساعه القادمه بعد
وصول الطائره من مطار برج سودان بعد ان تم
اجلاهم من الخرطوم برا الى بورتسودان ومن
ثم سوف يصلون الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه عبر الجو خلال الساعات القادمه
تحمل على متنها 29 شخص من الجنسيه الكوريه
هم جميعهم دبلوماسيين بمقدمتهم السفير
الكوري في السودان سوف يقوم باستقبالهم
الكوري في السعوديه وعدد من القيادات
الامنيه هنا سوف يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر في لحظه وصولهم من خلال المديريه
العامه للجوازات وكذلك الجمارك في تسهيل
عليهم
ويستطيعون فور او خلال ساعه واحده فقط بعد
وصولهم الى القاعده السفر عبر هذه الطائره
العسكريه الضخمه وصولا الى سيول في كوريا
الجنوبيه نتحدث ان هذه الرحله هي اول رحله
اخلاء جوي تصل الى السعوديه عبر مطار
بوتسودان تحط رحاله خلال الساعات القادمه
الى مطار قاعده القاعده الجويه او قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده سبقها خلال
يومين الماضيه عمليات اجلاء بحريه عبر
اربعه سفن وصل عددهم الى 157 شخص من ضمنهم
91 مواطن سعودي و66 مواطن اجنبي وخليجي
وعربي وكذلك من دول اوروبيه نتحدث على
بلغاريا وكندا ولكن نؤكد انه سوف تكون
الطائره الكوريه عمليه الاجلاء الاولى
الجويه سوف تصل الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه خلال الساعتين القادمه ومن ثم سوف
يتم نقلهم عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه
الكوريه بعد تنسيق امني كبير بين الحكومه
السعوديه والحكومه الكوريه لتسهيل
اجراءاتهم وفتح المجال لهم وانهاء كافه
الاجراءات المتعلقه بهم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات